life hack a gun free America in five
easy steps for a gun free America the
first thing you'll need is two-thirds of
Congress so elect a minimum of 67
senators and 290 representatives who are
on your side then have them vote to
propose an amendment to the Constitution
which repeals Second Amendment gun
rights for all Americans
then convince the legislators of 38
states to ratify that amendment
congratulations
the Second Amendment is now history at
this point you've done absolutely
nothing to decrease gun violence all
you've done is remove the barrier for
Congress to legally act you need to
enact common-sense gun reform you can
try to do what Australia did and and all
guns that's that's not at all what they
did but whatever [ __ ] it go big or go
home right get that law passed by
Congress and signed by the president
great the law is passed and guns are now
illegal the only thing left to do is
enforce the law guns don't just
disappear because you passed a law you
need to confiscate over 350 million guns
scattered among over 330 million
Americans sure you can try a buyback
program like Australia but like
Australia that will still leave behind
anywhere from 60 to 80 percent of
privately owned firearms the rest of
them you have to take you'll need the
police the FBI the ATF the National
Guard all known for their nuanced
approach to potentially dangerous
situations to go door to door through
3.8 million square miles of this country
and take them by force from thousands if
not millions of well-armed individuals
many of whom would rather start a civil
war than at
so inevitably gun violence which is
currently at a historic low will
skyrocket but that is how you get a gun
free America in five easy steps
you